[Música]
todos
y si te dijera
que todos tenemos un maravilloso lado
divertido
para muchos no pasaría sencillamente
nada porque ya lo conocen han visto
desde hace tiempo es el lado divertido
lo saben muy bien y en realidad no es
una gran gran sorpresa pero si te dijera
que es el lado divertido no es una
molestia
y me dirijo en este momento a todos esos
niños niñas jóvenes que nos hemos
convertido en adultos y que en algún
momento crecimos escuchando que es el
lado divertido es el lado comediante ese
humorista interior que buscaba salir
constantemente era reprendido reprimido
era aplacado y era tratado de ocultar
debido a ese carácter y a esa naturaleza
intempestiva inoportuna para muchos no
pasará sencillamente nada si les digo
que todos seremos un lado divertido
porque sencillamente no lo utilizan
sencillamente la vida no es tan
divertida como aparece y eso hay que
dejárselo a los extrovertidos pérez a la
persona que tienes al lado y mira si
tiene cara de extrovertido o de
introvertido
es muy fácil reconocerlos
si yo sé qué horror hay algunos que son
extremadamente introvertidos
durante mucho tiempo
quise convertirme en muchas cosas quise
convertirme y ha tenido la oportunidad
de lograrlo quise convertirme en el papá
que nunca tuve que convertirme en el
maestro al que siempre quise escuchar y
finalmente tuve una oportunidad después
de darlo todo después de arriesgarlo
todo de convertirme en el comediante que
siempre quise ver ese comediante que
latía dentro de mí y que buscaba una
oportunidad para salir esa oportunidad
llegó cuando finalmente tomé la decisión
de salir del closet ocupacional y así
como el día de hoy hemos visto
diferentes metáforas también hay un
closet y está más que una metáfora es
una realidad es una es un estado en el
cual trabajas en algo pero sabes que tu
corazón te llama y tu cabeza está
ocupada y una vocecita interior te dice
vos no sos de aquí vos deberías estar
haciendo otra cosa diferente deberías
estar enfocado en otra cosa cuando
finalmente me arriesgue me paré frente a
esas personas que tanto me querían y que
yo tanto quería mi familia mis
compañeros
mis jefes y los miré a los ojos y con
esa voz que ponemos los hombres cuando
vamos a decir cosas serias no nos
paramos duro y tenemos conversaciones
difíciles los mire a todos y les dije me
apena con ustedes yo
más decepcionante yo no puedo ser la
verdad yo
yo tengo que decirles la verdad lo que
lo que yo soy yo atrás de psicólogo
imagínense en latinoamérica como está la
psicología ahorita y dios mío de sally
psicólogo y yo no puedo aguantar más
esto yo la verdad yo soy comediante
entonces escucharon esas voces algunas
eran muy complacientes algunas eran eran
bastante complacientes algunos ni
siquiera me habían puesto atención
acostumbrados a este tipo de cosas
algunos eran muy complacientes entonces
me miraban
eso era todo
[Música]
para semejante bobada no reúne a todos
si ustedes ya se le notaba que usted era
comediante ya sé cuánto tiempo hombre as
pelota en el caminado es uno se le nota
que antes dices eso se sabe yo sabía eso
no hay que esconderlo no hay que decirle
nada de eso si se me antiguo bar otros
eran un poco más
eran un poco más cómplices no
voy a su estudio
tranquilo usted lo que quiere
experimentar
vaya experimente vaya desde una vueltica
desde el gusto de hacer lo que quiere y
vuelve que quiere encontrar su trabajito
estable no se preocupe a que experimente
viva cosas nuevas y esos son etapas
y otros serán un poco más alarmistas
entonces ante semejante verdad dios mío
está otra vez con esa sola ya pensamos
que lo habíamos superado ya que pónganse
serio en la vida usted ya tiene
obligación es un mal hecho y derecho más
de 30 años sobre y comediante eso es
gente por allá de otras cosas un
comediante la gente que ha hombre tiene
que ser una persona del promedio del
común ya no tiene todo hecho para que se
va a poner a buscar otras cosas no se
incomode y póngase serio y fue una de
las palabras una de las expresiones que
me quedó sonando póngase serio como si
ser comediante no fuera algo serio no y
si lo sé a los comediantes se nos
atribuyen una cantidad de estereotipos y
hay una cantidad imaginarios al respecto
somos sensuales
somos absolutamente divertidos todo el
tiempo lo que es absolutamente falso
donde no hay nada peor que encontrarse
de pronto con la calle está hecho
martínez martínez
contame algo divertido contraste un
chiste alguna cosa así que mira que
vengo así como medio bajón y aunque eso
no es mi responsabilidad qué pena
a veces no puedo cargar ni con mi propia
existencia
y qué hago yo contar minutos de chiste
no es posible y todos esos estereotipos
también están relacionados con que si
uno trabaja en algo divertido no es
trabajo
mi primera meta era confrontar ese mito
si trabajas o
si te diviertes mientras trabajas no es
un trabajo serio y nos acostumbramos y
cargamos en nuestra cabeza porque así
nos enseñaron cargamos en nuestra cabeza
que trabajar tenía que ser una torre
logra trabajar tenía que ser algo de
sufrimiento uno tenía que arrugar si
todavía tengo esa cicatriz para mí es
una cicatriz no es una arruga es una
cicatriz de una madurez precoz no
tratando de madurar para poder encajar
qué horror y lo que hace con su propio
cuerpo es una cosa increíble
tiene que estar con el seño fruncido
todo el tiempo y tiene que estar
concentrado y tiene que hablar mal y
tiene que estar estresado para que sea
para que sea curiosamente me di cuenta
al ejercer y al fusionar la psicología
con la comedia me di cuenta que cuando
unía estas dos cosas surgía algo
absolutamente explosivo pero yo no me
había topado con nada que ya no
existiera
el humor es una válvula natural de la
tensión en los colectivos humanos he
dicho el humor es una válvula natural
que libera la atención en los colectivos
humanos estamos trabajando en grupo
estamos trabajando colectivo en la
oficina hay que tener el informe esta
licitación se nos va dando la van a
quitar ese cliente hasta que se va mire
cómo está el entorno mire cómo está el
mercado de cómo estar y una presión
constante
y ya se sigue llenando y todo el mundo
además tiene sus problemas porque tienen
hijos tienen deudas y tiene una cantidad
cosas el hecho de estar vivo ya de por
sí genera la cantidad de cargas y
aparece alguien absolutamente divertido
a mí me encanta estas escenas de las
películas cuando la gente tiene que
cortar un cable y desactivar una bomba y
está en una cuenta regresiva cable azul
o cable rojo y esa es nuestra vida
cotidiana es lo que de lo que creemos y
lo que decimos que significa madurar
estar a punto de desactivar una bomba
cotidiana y que recoger a los niños 10
hay que ir a la reunión de padres el 9
hay que pagar la cuota 8 que no alcanzó
el sueldo 7 otra vez hay que almorzar en
texas 6 otra vez y 54 contestamos y ahí
reunión de comités perdón en las
reuniones de comité deberían estar
patrocinadas por casas de maquillaje no
las cifras nunca fueron tan bellas y tan
embellecidas y es una reunión donde uno
se sienta con esa propiedad su comité
uno se sienta
buenas atrás la verdad más atrás además
está trabajando fuertemente sin embargo
para los números no nos han acompañado
en este momento los indicadores mansilla
en este momento y todos los demás están
esperando a ver cómo se retiran pues es
que nosotros no hemos podido tampoco
lograr nada porque como ellos me han
lograr y estamos concatenar
en realidad el modelo horizontal de la
organización no está venido perjudicando
nosotros será mucho más fácil
movilizarnos en una organización
vertical fascista sin embargo nosotros
3 y entonces tenemos que dos está
a punto de estallar la vida nos basta ya
en realidad para atrás atrás en esa
escena siempre aparece el que casi todo
tranquilo estacional
siempre es una válvula que se libera te
libera a la presión natural del simple
hecho de convivir y de estar cerca
este comediante interior que tienes es
absolutamente necesario necesitamos que
en donde estés deje salir este
comediante interior pero papá papá papá
hay niveles de comedia y hay niveles de
oportunidad es el comediante cuando se
ejercita constantemente se ejercita en
el arte de aligerar la carga a otros de
liberar la atención en otros se entrena
en la función sagrada de ser un agente
de transformación sí y hay gente que me
está mirando en este momento los que nos
están viendo también están creando
s espaciales es tomar el pelo
seria se convierte en un agente
absolutamente transformador y
dinamizador cuando el comediante se
empodera de su rol cuando el humorista
nato se empodera se reconoce sale del
clóset de ocupacional y dice sí así soy
yo
yo soy así soy el divertido del paseo
soy el alma de esta fiesta soy la razón
por la cual logramos que nuestra
convivencia fluya mucho más fácilmente
cuando eso se logra el comediante pasa
un siguiente nivel y es
el de servir
no es un comediante que utiliza a los
demás para abrir brechas no es un
comediante que utiliza a los demás para
solo para posicionarse frente a su grupo
es un comediante que tiene una
responsabilidad social absolutamente
poderosa es un comediante encargado de
unir a las personas a partir del humor
es un comediante que transforma energía
y dinamiza mira la persona que tienes al
lado y quiero que te des cuenta si esa
persona podría ser un agente de dinamia
hay unos que dan tristeza de verdad no
los videos ay sí hay gente quiero la
mirandesa y tienen enseñar a la gente
dinamizador de nada
una vez
en serio dos cables de esos dos polos
opuestos ejercía plantó hace falta sin
reiniciar la batería porque de verdad
dios mío está suspendido
en un letargo infinito en una
actualización del sistema constante
independientemente de que sea es una
persona más introvertida y más pasiva
tienes la capacidad de ser un
dinamizador este comediante este
comediante que todos tenemos dentro es
absolutamente necesario en los
ecosistemas en las familias en los
trabajos en los colectivos somos no una
molestia como nos decían en el colegio
bájese de ahí es cuál es el chiste
traiga la maleta para que traiga la
traiga la traga tome usted la clase
entonces cuéntenos existe para todos
cuál es la risa entonces
esto entonces pregúntele a su compañero
pregúntele a su compañera a mí me pagan
igual
aprendan o no aprendan a terminar ese
tipo de cosas con las cuales crecimos
alpacas stereo madure
esto no se puede decir nada hombre de
verdad
y ese tipo de cosas que escuchamos
cuando las elevamos de nivel cuando nos
profesionalizamos cuando nos reconocemos
como personas dignas de ocupar ese rol
de ser la persona divertida el
comediante del equipo la válvula de
escape de tensión nos convertimos en un
agente transformador necesitamos mirar
la persona que tienes al lado y dile
necesito
todos los necesitamos de tu lado
divertido regálame una sonrisa aunque no
tengas las piezas dentales completas
y es si no puede ser tampoco un
obstáculo damas y caballeros soy sergio
martínez y mi rol es hacer que se
enamoren no solamente de su trabajo sino
en su lado divertido mi defecto era no
tomarme las cosas muy en serio pero de
verdad que ser un agente dinamizador de
cambio a partir del humor es una de las
cosas más serias y más fabulosas que he
hecho muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
vivo